let me be specific about those beats
because i've said them you know said
that word a lot um but i'm talking
specifically about the normal
the inciting incident
the goal or the problem
what is your process for teaching
screenplay structure yeah so
i start with this great the screenplay i
start with the pixar formula
from the pixar formula i go into
character work i am
someone in my own time who likes to
psychoanalyze things i'm always asking
people why how you know what what
happened to you and so we do some work
like that for the characters the more
that you understand uh people the more
you can understand your characters who
are people so in my class which may make
some people uncomfortable
but in my class we talk about ourselves
a lot we're doing a lot of inner work
because my class is also about
fighting writer's block and in my
opinion writer's block comes from lack
of confidence and lack of preparation so
we spend a lot of time talking about
confidence talking about what our fears
are what our flaws are what our wants
are what's standing in the way of those
wants why because that's what's
happening for your characters what do
they want what do they need what's
standing in the way of that what are
they what are they afraid of what are
their flaws that are going to get in the
way of them getting the thing that they
want right so if you start to understand
how your own life the life of your tribe
members i call my classes tribes the
life of your tribe members um
if you start to understand why they do
the things they do then you start to
understand characters a little bit more
and now your characters can be more
authentic in their journey because
oftentimes i can feel the writer making
characters do things
versus it feeling like an actual
decision that the character would make
so we spend some time on characters
so i'd say that's week two that's
actually just what i did on a couple of
days ago week two that was last night it
was just last night
it's hard to keep up with time these
days um it's all one it's all one big
thing uh then we um start to talk about
goal setting
um because every single story is about
your protagonist solving a problem
reaching a goal that's why we are here
so we have to figure out what's the best
goal for them to reach or who's the best
character for that goal depending upon
which one you begin with um and then we
start talking about now how are they
physically going to achieve it because
again going back to they need to save
the world well that's general
what are they going to do how are they
going to save it and start asking
ourselves well what are the things that
get in the way so in the
fourth week we start talking about the
complications we started talking about
the stakes um in week three we also talk
about world building um
because
every single story
you have to teach us the rules of that
world
if it's just regular old present-day
earth something that we see in the first
three minutes are gonna tell me that
that's what it is so you're still
teaching me right if it's um a new
industry like i love to use devil the
devil wears prada right i'm not in the
fashion industry so you have to teach me
how it works here right so they open up
by showing me how all the other women
are nicely dressed and our protagonist
is not right they show us by when she
gets into that office how everyone is
looking at her judging her and then when
meryl streep's character is going to
show up everybody it's chaotic because
they're trying to make sure they get in
line i'm learning about this industry
right i'm learning about what the rules
are here even if there's not much being
said out loud so we talk about that and
especially if you're doing something
that's science fiction fantasy
supernatural horror then there are rules
you have to set up i need to know
candyman comes when i say it how many
times right because if not then i don't
have the suspense
now if i see a person standing in the
mirror and they only say it twice should
i be afraid because i don't know how
many times they're supposed to say it if
i understand they have to say it five
times i don't even remember if it's five
or three but they have to say it x
amount of times and now i know when she
gets on number four
that i should be on the edge of my seat
but i don't know that if you haven't
given me the information
so we talk about world building um and
then in the last week that's when we
finally start talking about outlining
because i want people to know there's
not one way to do it right you can do it
a million different ways so i show them
different examples of how you can
outline but all of those things that
we're learning basically uh break into
those large beats and let me be specific
about those beats because i've said them
you know said that word a lot um but i'm
talking specifically about the normal
the inciting incident
the goal or the problem
getting into act two
knowing what your midpoint is knowing
what your rock bottom you know is
knowing what your point of no return is
which some people kind of mix into that
rock bottom midpoint place it basically
just means we get to a place where
something changes
so much that our character has to change
tactics that's just all it means
everybody gives it a different word
right
but then we got to get up to our climax
which is your highest point when your
bad guy is going to meet your good guy
or your character is going to meet their
problem head on and then we get to come
down to the resolution where we say what
have they won because they you know
succeeded or what did they lose because
they didn't yet throughout that entire
journey we were following them
emotionally so even if they didn't
succeed we still feel satisfaction with
the story so all of those beats
are what i mean when i'm saying
structure
all of those beats fit into your act one
act two and act three and so i utilize
those different weeks to talk about
those different um
elements because they all break into
those big beats
and how can you tell and i realize this
is very specific and we don't have
something to workshop but
just vaguely when someone is really
forcing an action from their character
it can be because
the evidence is just not on the page
or the evidence is on the page and your
character isn't doing what you've told
us that they do right so if you've said
this is a really shy character every
single thing you've shown us is that
they're shy and then on page 15 they
stand on top of a table and dance
what that's not who you told me this
person was so unless you showed me
something that motivated this
right
then now i know you just needed her on a
table dancing
because of whatever else is going to
happen in the screenplay not because she
would get on that table and dance i see
okay yeah so we're missing what would
ever cause that if this was truly what
the characters would do okay yeah so
we're missing that so either it's just
not there at all or it's the opposite of
what you told us yeah and so it's like
we know that you needed this character
to end up in jail because
now the son has to avenge
you know whatever's going on with with
the parent being in jail
but
it isn't set up that our character would
have even done any of those things that
they did to be in jail so now i know
you're just forcing them
into this position
because of what you need to happen from
that so it's like you got to set me up
with the information so i can believe it
because if i don't believe it then now
now the stakes aren't as high you know
now you just start to lose me as a as an
audience member yeah so it's just like i
need the evidence so that's a lot of
what i'll write in my notes i don't
there's no evidence of this this doesn't
ring true you know like where did this
happen when do we meet that well you
said on page this that this is how they
feel but on page this they feel this way
what motivated that change where where
was that
because maybe i missed it i probably
didn't but maybe i missed it
but if i didn't if i didn't miss it then
now you know it's missing and you can
figure out how to make that connection
because everything is cause and effect
people are cause and effect if i have an
argument in this room when i walk into
that room my energy is going to be
different if i had not had an argument
in this room so the same thing is true
about your characters why are they doing
the stuff that they're doing what
happened on the page
to show me
that motivates
any of their decisions